there are so many po tricks that look
beautiful with the POI long but at the
same time there are so many po tricks
that work much better with the POI short
how do you go back and forth between
those two lengths that is the topic
we're exploring
today Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're talking
about how you change the length of your
POI on the fly to get a variety of
different effects and hit up a bunch of
different tricks but before we dive in I
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys pyroa
light toys and Ultra for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non business
friend of the channel Becca Becket thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission as I'm
recording this video it definitely has
to be said that long poi are what's in
Vogue right now and it's pretty easy to
see why longer po are visible from much
further away they make all those
intricate catches much much easier just
by virtue of being a bigger Target to
catch and they give the performer a lot
more leeway when playing around with
things like negative space but that
doesn't mean there might not be reasons
why you want to shorten up the PO to try
other tricks but how exactly do you go
from long to short and then perhaps to
long again well that's what we're going
to cover here real quickly before we
dive in if you want to see more video on
pois spinning and flow Arts be sure to
subscribe and ring the bell so you know
when I drop a new video thanks all right
so first and foremost I think it should
be said that I think of Po as having
three specific possible lengths I'll
refer to them as large medium and small
the large length happens when we are
gripping right next to the handle
usually just this little piece of tether
that comes out from it and we're using
the handle itself basically as a stopper
to uh keep the entire POI from going out
from between our fingers next we have
what I would call the medium grip now
the medium grip can be accomplished in
one of two ways it's either you move
your grip just slightly up in which case
now instead of the handle being a
stopper that goes between two fingers
it's now a stopper that comes out at the
very very end of your hand and instead
you're going to be grabbing the entire
tether with your hand another means that
you can get to this point is you can
actually wrap the tether just around
your first two fingers your index and
middle finger like so this used to be
the most common way that I would shorten
up grip like this but either way you
wind up in a place where you have now
choked up on the tether by probably a
good 2 or 3 in and finally the short
grip and I think there's pretty much
only one way to do this and that is to
wrap the entire tether around around
your hand once so just to review we have
a full length version that basically
goes the full length of the arm we have
a medium length which generally goes to
about mid bicep and we have a short
length that goes right about to your
elbow so what would we use each of these
three different lengths and grips for we
use full length most often for flowers
windmills and other po moves that
require large amount of volume and that
you want to be seen from far
away it's also the default length when
you're doing any kind of contact po as
well as throws because well there's no
way to wrap up the tether when it's just
flying through the air medium grip is
fantastic for what I'll call Old School
Tech poy that is all those intricate
patterns based around cat eyes and
tretas and the like in addition it's
also a good length for exploring plane
braks it gives you just enough distance
to be able to do some really beautiful
stalls while at the same time being
short enough that the Stalls are not
totally impossible to nail cleanly the
shortest length on the other hand is
great for training stalls with less
tether to have to worry about stalls
wind up coming out just a bit more
stable and a bit more clean this is a
great training mode if you're just
getting down your PO stalls for the
first time in addition they're really
helpful for po moves that involve moving
through very cramped and tight spaces in
particular Buzz saws toids and of course
inside planes all work really really
well with this length of Po and there is
also one additional use for these three
different lengths that I think kind of
goes under the radar they're a fantastic
tool for matching beats with whatever
music you're listening to whenever I'm
listening to music I'll try spending the
poy at all three different lengths and
see which one most comfortably fits such
that I complete one beat with the poy
for Every Beat of the Music when I lock
into this I tend to find that all of my
spinning Transitions and stalls tend to
fit in perfectly with the tempo of the
music this is a great cliffs notes way
of being able to lock in with any beat
[Music]
okay so now that we' talked at length
about uses for different lengths of poi
let's talk about how you actually
achieve them without a doubt the most
important skill you're going to need to
learn how to do is going to be wrapping
the poy around your hand and then being
able to unwrap it this is a skill that
glow stringers refer to as a shotgun
here's how you do it as you're spinning
the poy I want you to go ahead and move
from this grip here where we have the
key grip and we're pinching the tether
between our thumb and index finger and I
want you to go ahead and just uh hold
your thumb against the side of your hand
like this so that you can keep the
handle in a tight grip while the rest of
your fingers extend outward so from the
key grip I just use my thumb to pull
against my palm like so and now I can
extend all of my fingers from here if I
extend the fing fingers outward
basically perpendicular to the plane of
the POI the POI starts wrapping around
them I can either wrap once or I can
wrap twice and then of course I can
unwrap if I want to so from spinning I
extend my fingers to wrap around once
and I close my fingers once again to get
to the half length grip and of course I
can use the same technique to get to the
medium length grip by extending only my
index and middle fingers boom and then
pulling them back into my palm when I
reach the grip that I want TAA to get
back out of either one of these shorter
grips there's a few ways of doing it
number one is if you change your plane
facing that is the direction the POI
seems to be spinning relative to you you
can once again open up your hand and
that will allow the POI to unspool from
around your arm easy peasy another
option would be simply to just let go of
your fingers and let the POI come loose
sometimes it's a great effect sometimes
it looks a little sloppy and of course
there's always the option of bringing
the PO to a stop and then releasing it
and then setting it going once again all
these are fine options there is of
course one other way that you can get to
the medium grip and that is to kind of
slowly crawl your fingers up the tether
until you get to a point where you've
got the entire tether draped across your
palm as you spin the poy the way this is
done is that you reach ahead pinch the
tether a little bit and pull it back
towards your palm you then grip onto it
with the other fingers and once again
extend your thumb and index finger to
crawl it up another couple inches it's
not exactly the most dignified way of
doing things but it is effective I just
made that grip change and the audience
is none the wiser and of course to get
back out of this all you have to do is
loosen your grip just a little bit and
the centrifugal force of the POI will
pull it all the way back out and you
return to your full length grip so to
review I just got it to medium length
and now I just got it to full length
just like that easy peasy and of course
there's all sorts of wonderful indos
syncratic ways that you can find to both
wrap the poy up as well as unwrap them
you can say wrap them in one place in
wall plane and unwrap them in another
place in wall plane you can wrap them up
in buzs saww and unwrap them when you
return to wheel plane you can make the
wrapping and unwrapping happen all in
one side of you you can make the
wrapping happen on one side and the
unwrapping happen on another side
there's so many options here all it
really takes is keeping a awareness of
what side of the poy plane your hand
happens to be on and how you can switch
over to the other plane in order to
reverse the direction of the wrapping
and thus lengthen or shorten the poy
accordingly awesome I hope this guide
was helpful not only to give you an idea
of why you might want to use all these
different lengths but also how to
achieve them as you're spinning please
make sure to tag me in whatever videos
you record as a result of learning these
techniques I'd love to see your hard
work and please remember to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video and of course of course
to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all rock thank you so
much and if you out there watching are
not currently a supporter but you'd like
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon at
patreon.com Factor Po and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but better than that
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring po spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you and if you're
curious how long your Poise should be in
the first place I did a video on that
topic that I'll go ahead and link to
down in the description as well as up on
screen hopefully that will help you
narrow it down cuz there is a whole
bunch of possible lengths out there
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow yourself today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace